Speaker 1: We have new polling and it is it
is remarkable.
It has been 15 years since Americans were
as optimistic about the future of the country
as they are today.
To new polls again confirm some things that
we already knew.
Americans largely approve of Joe Biden's performance
as president so far, but the polls were also
asking about American optimism more generally.
And an ABC Ipsos poll finds that almost two
thirds of Americans are optimistic about the
next year.
Americans have not been this optimistic about
the year to come since two thousand six per
the same ABC poll.
A second poll released by Yahoo!
News and YouGov finds that 57 percent of the
country approves of Joe Biden's handling of
the pandemic.
When asked if Biden's performance was better,
worse or the same than expected, the plurality
39 percent, said Biden is doing even better
than expected.
Twenty eight percent said worse.
Twenty four percent said about what we expected.
And overall, Joe Biden has a fifty four percent
approval rating.
Now, you and I might see that in, say, fifty
four.
That's not that's not so good.
That's not a very high number.
Remember that Donald Trump never hit 50 percent,
even on a single day of his presidency and
was plagued by approval in the 30s for the
most part, and even twenty nine percent when
he left office.
So this this is a change for sure.
Now, in terms of the country being divided,
this is this is interesting and not great
numbers for Joe Biden.
Twenty eight percent of Americans believe
that the country is more divided since Joe
Biden took office.
Twenty three percent believe it is.
I'm sorry.
Twenty three percent say more divided.
Twenty eight percent say less divided.
That is interesting because everybody's blaming
Biden.
The people that think the country is more
united.
I think it's more united because of Joe Biden.
The people that think the country is more
divided also think it's more divided because
of Joe Biden.
But what's clear is that overall politics
has become a lot more boring and people seem
to be OK with that.
Now, fascinatingly, there was the assumption
that because things would be boring under
Joe Biden, shows like The David Pakman Show
wouldn't do well.
In fact, there were gleeful.
Trump is saying, David, when Trump is gone,
your show will be circling the drain, which
is a phrase we've been hearing for 15 years
that we keep growing.
But put that aside for a second.
I assumed we would we would see a decline
in viewership.
Corporate media has seen a big decline in
viewership since Trump has left.
But then something I really don't understand
happened because I was prepared for like a
full year of really things being pretty slow
in late March, then early April, mid-April,
April just finished.
The numbers came that back very strong.
There were no Biden scandals, nothing in the
Biden administration even coming close to
the insanity of the Trump White House, and
yet that dip we saw that we see after every
election in January and February and early
March, it's almost completely recovered.
We were back up to 30 million views in April,
12 million views on Facebook.
These are like 20, 20 numbers once again.
So I'm curious what you think is going on,
because things are kind of boring in a sort
of salacious from a salacious evaluation type
standpoint.
TV networks are reporting significantly lower
ratings.
Trump, no doubt, was good for ratings.
And yet.
We're almost back to where we were in December,
which was a record month, not all the way,
maybe eighty five percent of the way there,
if you look at what did best in April.
There's some Trump stuff in there that's left
over that he's still doing things, but it's
a lot of other things.
Clip's about right wingers who just call into
the show to talk to him.
He did really well.
The Matt Gate scandal got a lot of attention.
Critiques of right wing media framing did
well reporting on some of these corporate
scams, Foxconn and others, coverage of the
Derik Shervin trial, stories about vaccine
conspiracies and other things.
At this point, there's like seven or eight
different general areas of content that are
doing very well.
So something is going on.
It's not only that people are more optimistic
than they've been for 15 years, they're optimistic,
but they're also not tuning out.
If it bleeds, it leads.
You know, we know about that.
If people are satisfied and complacent rather
than panicked, they tend to watch a lot less
news.
But yet people are watching almost as much
of the show as they were in December.
The most optimistic interpretation I have
is people recognize that things are going
in the right direction, but realize that if
we tune out now and not pay attention to what's
going on, maybe we get Trump or something
like him back in twenty twenty for the real
explanation.
Could be anything I'd be curious to hear from,
from you.
Why is most of that election peak audience
already back?
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Very interested in hearing from.